Anastasia is with us in California hi
Anastasia how are you hello hello thank
you for taking my call
sure what's up so I'm a single mom of
three and so yeah we do not rejoice
awards but he doesn't live with me okay
and um I have a hundred K cash and my
question is basically what should i do
should I did a degree should I invest it
or should I um or should I
I really want to buy a business like I
could work in it or should I just like
invest those money in a business how'd
you get 100 grand
well we sold that oh yeah I'll say you
were living with your boyfriend and you
sold the house and you got half the
money no no my husband oh oh but you
said you were a single mom single mom
with right now yes I am so you're
divorced
not legally but we just haven't a minute
together okay you're not a single mom if
you're married there's a definition
problem here I understand you kicked him
out because he's got an addiction
problem but and you then you sold the
house and you got to keep the money and
he's off handling his addiction right
well he got to keep some of the money as
well so he got half of the money when I
got another half of the money so we kind
of put it no so where are you gonna be
five years from now still married to a
guy who's addicted addicted to stuff and
that you don't live with no no no no I
mean I'm going through the papers and
stuff too started all that stuff but
yeah the process is all you know I'm
doing the paper a long time alright so
you're a future single mom then okay and
you have $100,000 how old are you how
old are your babies
77042 okay and what do you do for a
living now
nothing what are you living on well I
would I live with my parents right now
it's like a depicts and I live on the
other side and um she was paying rent
for a while it was the last time you
worked that was five years ago
so he was paying the bills or your
parents were no he wants to she was he
was making really good money and the
chapters addiction was up and down up
and down and when she was doing good she
was making good money and then when evil
does y'all doing you know crazy stuff we
would still have money to live on how
much the first thing we've got to invest
in then is you in your future and so you
need to do some discussing and praying
and reading and thinking about what you
want to be doing when you're 39 years
old that you make really good money ten
years from now what does your life look
like and what are the steps to get there
a degree generally might be a good idea
it might not be a good idea but don't
just run off and get a degree because
you're gonna transition you need to be
doing something that is a step to take
you towards where you want to be when
you're thirty nine ten years from now
and I want you to be a highly successful
woman making $100,000 a year ten years
from now
now what are you going to be doing to do
that ready set go to buy a business but
the money I have you don't know how to
run a business
I can I can mention put everything into
it like I know you can put all that
money in and lose it you don't need to
buy a business you have absolutely ever
worked in four years you haven't told me
anything this conversation educates you
know how to run a business
I would love for you to get to where you
can learn to run a business and maybe
you want to take some classes and learn
about that or maybe you go to work for
someone that runs businesses or small
businesses and you learn from them and
then later on you buy a business that's
okay but right now you're just desperate
and flailing around with a hundred grand
in your hand and that makes you
dangerous to yourself calm down
develop a solid plan for the next decade
and where that's going to take you and
then take solid gentle incremental steps
and that'll get you there